bei uns ist robert habeck einer der zwei
vorsitzenden von bündnis90 die grünen
er habe ich gleich irgendwie sind die
grünen die der spielverderber sind sie
doch nicht die neuen grünen sondern die
alten grünen alle wollen doch jetzt
vielleicht erstmal loslegen
sie haben gerade gesagt das thema ist
alt und jetzt zu sagen wir haben 2021
wir müssen das klima schützen das
natürlich absurd
und wenn ich kurz was zu dieser
kurzstreckenflug debatte sagen darf sie
ist völlig falsch rum aufgezogen
wenn mir ist noch nicht mal schaffen so
etwas lächerlich ist wie bin flügel
sagen wir von stuttgart nach frankfurt
in den griff zu bekommen
wie wollen wir dann die wirklich großen
herausforderungen den gesamten
gebäudebestand bis mitte der 40er jahre
klimaneutral hinzubekommen zu machen
dann darüber muss man diskutieren weil
sie können ja durchaus sich auch mal aus
der sicht des wählers mit der frage
befassen wie das eigentlich für jemanden
aus schaut der sieht dass zukünftig
nicht mehr leisten können wird und
gerrit nach frankfurt zu früh naja
vielleicht also dann nach münchen er von
berlin um dann irgendwie ins allgäu zu
kommen oder auch berliner hamburg keine
ahnung das ist eingestellt das kann man
nicht mehr
berlin/frankfurt also man muss jetzt ein
bisschen trennen bei kurzstreckenflügen
geht es eher aus meiner sicht um ein
symbol
die lohan fuß der klima der
klimawirksame gewinnen ist nicht so
besonders gut das muss man einfach
zugeben es ist eher ein beispiel dafür
was man alles machen kann das wirklich
niemandem wirklich weh tut
die ökologen die ökologische ökonomische
frage also wieder fliegen wird es davon
zu trennen
wieder fliegen wird ist davon zu trennen
trotzdem die eu hatte sich ja mal für
einen sehr marktwirtschaftliches
instrument nämlich den emissionshandel
beim fliegen verständigt das reicht
ihnen da nicht oder reicht ihrer
parteivorsitzenden und gar selber
niederhalten der emissionshandel und
auch dann die nationale co2 bepreisung
in den sektoren wo der emissionshandel
also die europäische co2 preis nicht
gilt ist ein starkes lenkungsinstrument
deswegen ist es vor anderthalb jahren
geschlossen worden und es ist gut dass
müsste stärker wirken stärker ansteigen
in der damit die lenkungswirkung sich
wirklich entfalten kann aber die
betonung liegt auf ist es ein
lenkungsinstrument wenn man alles über
den preis regeln will alles dem gesamten
klimaschutz über den preis macht dann
hat man wirklich ein soziales problem
mannschaft
wann ein soziales problem weil sich dann
nur noch wirklich sehr sehr reiche leute
autos wo fliegen leisten können deswegen
ist ordnungspolitik gleichheit und wenn
es zu teuer ist als dass man es sich
leisten kann oder aber verboten ist ist
aus sicht eines betroffenen ärmeren
menschen doch aber egal wenn ist eine
gleichheit gipfeln ist kein flieger
zwischen stuttgart und frankfurt gibt
kann es darüber kann neid geben und dass
deswegen ist es nicht egal
umgekehrt wird ein schuh daraus es ist
ein lenkungsinstrument wie sich das die
wirtschaft die investitionen planen kann
dass die vermieter wissen wie sie ihr
gebäude sanieren welche heizsysteme sie
einbauen dass man es berechnen kann wie
sich der klimaschutz rechnet es ist nur
ein instrument wenn man darauf
verzichtet die anderen instrumente zu
nehmen und alles über den preis macht
wird es wirklich extrem teuer und das
ist auch der irrtum von sich
mitbewerbenden parteien für die
bundestagswahl alles über den preis zu
machen führt uns sehr schnell zu einem
co2 preis von 180 200 euro bieten
und da sind wir schon bei georg kofler
unternehmer investor eben mitgestalter
von der höhle des löwen wurde die höhle
der löwen
sie haben herr kofler eine spende von
750.000 euro an die fdp gegeben und zwar
aus angst vor einer grünen kanzlerin
annalena baerbock
das muss eine ganz schön große angst
sein ist es auch eine angst davor dass
flüge verboten werden können etwas angst
ist eine völlig falsche kategorie das
klingt da viel zu defensiv ich bin ein
proaktiver mensch also unternehmer und
ich will werte unterstützen wie
marktwirtschaft unternehmertum ein
verantwortung leistungsbereitschaft und
die finde ich bei der fdp am besten
aufgehoben da kann ich mich als
unternehmer am besten wieder finden da
finde ich auch eine diese wertschätzung
für unternehmerische risikobereitschaft
und unternehmerische leistung also das
war ein positives signal
ein aktives signal kein defensives
signal aber natürlich auch mit der
absicht eine beteiligung nicht böse sein
ja der grünen an der bundesregierung zu
verhindern denn ich habe als investor
mag ja normalerweise immer die
sogenannte due diligence also das ist
ein kaufmännisches und jetzt habe ich
bei ihnen und bei der fdp eine
politische substanz prüfung gemacht und
da habe ich das fdp-wahlprogramm gelesen
74 seiten er ist ja noch viel länger 136
sein
und da ist mir einfach aufgefangen ich
bin richtig erschrocken dass hinter
diesen wohlklingenden hinter dieser
wohlklingenden klimaschutz
da brauchen sie mich gar nicht
überzeugend für klimaschutz aber dass da
lauter ich habe mal ein eine folter
werkstatt der sozialistischen
planwirtschaft ein billy ein der
register der register staat der nicht
moderne ist sie sagen wir wollen modern
sein erneuern hey bin ich gleich dabei
habe investiert und dutzende von jungen
firmen im social media und online
bereich bin nur umgeben von jungen
leuten ich bin wirklich aufgeschlossen
für jede neue idee und auch
unvoreingenommen um server bereit ihre
liebe zum klimaschutz das ist ja jetzt
er wirklich eine zentrale frage wo
fangen wir an uns zu verändern also
würden sie sagen diese inlandflüge
brauchen wir eigentlich nicht wirklich
und sie betreffen jetzt er nicht den
kleinen mann oder die kleine frau
sondern eher geschäftsreisende und da
könnte man sich auch mal was anders
überlegt bisher wirklich ein kleines
beispiel sagt er richtig dass das zehnte
hat er nicht viel das ist ja mehr symbol
ich halte es für ein falsches symbol und
wissen sie warum weil es weil es ein
verbot ist und jetzt sage ich wir müssen
doch kreativität einen ideenwettbewerb
an den daten und etwas verbieten das ist
nun ultima ratio also wenn einem gar
nichts mehr einfällt da verbietet ist
genau das problem auf was ich
hingewiesen habe die fdp will ja alles
über den preis regeln alles über den
preis keine normativen grenzen keine aus
steigungs ausstiegs grenzen keine
verbote von strecken
alles über den preis zu regeln heisst
wir müssen sich jetzt auch an die
gesetze halten bis 2030 den preis für
die tonne co2 enorm ansteigen zu lassen
wenn das das einzige instrument ist der
markt für sie sagen über den preis ein
längeres mechanismus dann schafft man
sozialen unfrieden in deutschland nach
das wäre und weil sie sagten wir das
klingt alles so wolkig und dann haben
sie total härten verbunden
das ist in die tasche gelogen das sind
totale haben sich damit verbinden
man sagt ets ein handelssystem und man
denkt oh mein handelssystem was kann
denn daran falsch sein
dieses handelssystem alleine als
einziges lenkungsinstrument für den
klimaschutz sorgt für soziale
verwerfungen in deutschland ok dann sind
wir noch mal herr kofler irgendwo
sammelt noch mal den gedanken den die
frage wie nächste frage geht an den
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
herr altmaier ausgerechnet ihr
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet sagt jetzt
das was die gründe fordern sei
populistisch sie können wirft den grünen
populismus vor und es sei irgendwie
typisch dass das jetzt von dieser partei
käme ist das wirklich populistisch oder
wie sie sind zu zitieren mit der
bemerkung dass wir demnächst mit einem
klimaneutralen jet von airbus in den
urlaub fliegen können ist das nicht
vielmehr populisten sein konnte dass es
kommt auf die ehrlichkeit an robert
habeck durchaus schätze hat gesagt ja er
ist dagegen dass über den preis zu
machen aber dann halten wir die kleinen
hängt man ja ganz gut auch ausreden aber
wir müssen gelangen ich habe sie einfach
nur die sich über den preis für zu einem
co2 preis von 180 bis 200 euro sehr
schnell
einzig über natürlich ich habe sie
versichert wurde dass holger weg wir
haben sie im bundesrat dazu gebracht ein
co2 preis einzuführen das war meine
partei die entscheidungen sie haben zeit
prozent der rede oben bisher nicht ich
bin sicher ich bin besser als ansagen
jahren genau benannte sie sollen sie
hatten die sollen mich nicht falsch
zitieren also ich finde also ich mir wir
haben immer die co2 sprechen beigebracht
versuche kontra zu geben und der
entscheidende punkt ist doch aber und
das ist die unehrlichkeit in ihrer
partei wenn wir würde das ernsten lassen
unehrlich
er habe drogen der ernst machen mit
klimaneutralität im jahre 2045 das steht
im gesetz drin da wird es überhaupt kein
fossiles kerosin mehr geben dann wird es
auch kein fossiles benzin mehr geben
dann werden wir keine fossilen
treibstoffe mehr verbrauchen
und da gibt es wenn man den leuten die
möglichkeit geben möchte auch dann noch
einmal oder zweimal im jahr urlaub zu
machen oder verwandte zu besuchen im
flugzeug wenn die entfernung und weit
sind nur eine möglichkeit dass wir
nämlich das unterstützen dass die
flugzeuge umgerüstet werden
auf klimaneutrale treibstoffe für die
dafür geben wir sehr viel geld aus dafür
geben wir eine milliarde aus indem wir
jetzt die flugzeugindustrie bei den
forschungen und umrüstungen unterstützen
wir machen synthetisches benzin
synthetisches kerosin mit energie aus
windkraft aus photovoltaik und das ist
die perspektive und die lösung alles
andere führt am ende dazu dass der
kleine mann immer die zeche zahlt wenn
es wird es ja einfach mal gar nichts
wenn sie den reichen verbieten zu
fliegen und die kleinen dürfen fliegen
weil es natürlich millionenfach mehr
kleine leute gibt die dann fliegen und
dann wird der co2 ausstoß immer noch so
hoch sein wie heute
auch dieses jet oder bis der jet dann
mit wasserstoff fliegt so lange fliegen
die armen dann in den harz oder an wir
haben nein wir haben wir haben
airbus hat vor
dieses modell bis etwa 20.30 zur
serienreife zu bringen für
mittelstreckenflüge die klötzer sind
gibt es so genanntes hybrid elektrisches
fliegen das ist eine kombination aus
batterie und brennstoffzellenantrieb
und im übrigen und im übrigen haben auch
die grünen nicht gefordert dass die
urlaubsreise nach mallorca den nächsten
jahren verbieten
das wäre auch mit meinem verständnis von
freiheit nicht zu vereinbaren wir haben
uns klare ziele gesetzt und diese ziele
können wir erreichen und dazu gehört
nicht ein verbot von flugreisen aber es
gehört dazu die bereitschaft vieles
anders zu machen als wir es bisher
gemacht und dann fangen wir doch mal
damit an uns zu fragen wie das gelingen
soll mayer gipfel ist bei uns sie ist
politik ökonomen centers for future
denkt denkt denn sie leitet heißen new
institute for people
das bundes
verfassungsgericht hat uns geholfen es
hat der politik beine gemacht um im
grunde etwas zu verhindern
was herr kofler als nächstes sehr
nämlich so was wie eine ökodiktatur
in den nächsten zehn jahren ja also wir
sind zwei wochen aber wahnsinnig wichtig
in dieser ganzen debatte und das eine
ist dass ich überhaupt keine lust habe
über kosten des klimaschutzes zu reden
ohne dass wir mindestens mit auf den
tisch legen die kosten des verweigern
des klimaschutzes machen weil da ist
inzwischen wirklich unter den ökonomen
und ökonomenkonsens es wird aus einer
reinen kosten für die logik wer viel
teurer wenn wir das nicht in griff
kriegen kosten nutzen rechnung genau
entschuldigung ja also jetzt können wir
in meiner entschuldigung
es geht immer nur darum was kostet uns
das jetzt aber vieles von dem sollten
als eine investition werden weil es uns
in zukunft und damit wir beim
bundesverfassungsgericht eben deutliche
freiheiten erlaubt noch anders agieren
zu können und was zweite punkt ist mir
ganz wichtig ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja die
währung gewechselt das hat nämlich
angefangen nicht in geldwerten sondern
in co2 äquivalenten zu rechnen und dann
zu sagen wir haben viel zu lange zu
wenig getan und deshalb ist jetzt auf
einmal die diskussion so erhitzt und so
angestrengt weil es jetzt der radikal
wirkt weil eben viele von den dingen zu
spät an den rand geschoben haben und das
ist auch immer wieder die botschaft aus
der wissenschaft gewesen je schneller
wir handeln umso weniger drastisch
werden die maßnahmen seien um sie länger
sind die übergangsfristen und jetzt
haben wir aber leider nicht mehr die
länge und es selbst hat muss es auch
heute und ab heute umgeben so schnell so
viel wie möglich also es gibt
tatsächlich berechnungen und scheint es
häufiger sagt übrigens bis 2030 80
prozent reduktion wäre eigentlich gerade
wenn man globale gerechtigkeit mitdenkt
das ehrlich erzieherin fragen der
ehrlichkeit sind und nicht nur 65
prozent
es gibt noch luft nach oben so die new
zealand in den industrieländern die
natürlich durch eine frisch und roh dazu
gerechnet
es geht darum das budget von einem land
was mit einer historischen rechnung und
vom kopf berechnung angetreten ist zu
sagen wieviel sollten wir denn jetzt
eigentlich reduzieren damit global
betrachtet ein ähnliches pro kopf budget
zur verfügung stünden und dann sind seit
meiner anderen rechnung also ist das ein
sehr liberal ist
ich bin ihnen darf ich würde ihn gern
verpflichten einen weiteren gast
vorstellen aber gerne noch versuchen sie
zusammenzufassen
sie sagen wir brauchen heute klimaschutz
damit wegen ökodiktatur morgen vermeiden
also wer angst hat vor verboten und
einer sogenannten ökologischen diktatur
der muss spätestens jetzt mit
klimaschutz anfangen ungefähr so ja das
interessante ist ja wie definiere ich
eine ökodiktatur viel scheint es ja
immer darauf bezogen zu sein ja dann
gibt es regulierung die leute maximal
ein schreck eine ökodiktatur kann man
auch zu verstehen dass dann sehr viele
umweltveränderungen stattfinden die kein
einzige regierung mehr abschaffen kann
und die uns dann diktiert was sind noch
die freiheitsgrade der zukunft den
generation und haben wir dann bestimmte
länder noch auf diesem planeten oder
sind wir halt einfach untergegangen also
das ist ein ziemlich diktatorischer
umgang heute mit denjenigen die am
meisten vom klimawandel oder chaos
betroffen wie das ist ein guter gedanke
den merken wir uns und begrüßen einen
geschätzten kollegen vom spiegel herr
drauf hätte hier in berlin und sitzt
auch in berlin
speziell die sie jetzt beiden spiegel
auf wirtschaft und verkehr und hat
gerald traufetter natürlich das urteil
aus karlsruhe auch gelesen und nicht nur
das warum sagen die menschen heute dass
das ein so wegweisend anderes urteil ist
die erkenntnisse dimensionen die wir den
klimaschutz betreffend wissen sind so
neu nicht
es ist richtig ja aber dass der große
unterschied
nach diesem urteil ist dass die
verfassungsrichter klar gemacht haben
dass das was wir uns an zielen gesetzt
haben dass die auch einzuhalten sind und
dann haben sie noch eine andere
bemerkenswerte sache festgestellt sie
haben sich nämlich angeguckt dieses
budget was sie eben ja auch schon
genannt haben von sechs milliarden
tonnen co2 was wir nur noch ausstossen
dürfen durch autos und durch unsere
industrie und da sind sie darauf
gekommen
moment mal jetzt wird noch gar nichts
gemacht und dann später also ab 2030 da
soll dann nachher eingespart werden nur
die generation die dann die dann
die dann lebt die kann dann praktisch
nicht mehr all diese dinge genießen die
wir genießen also das heißt ein massiver
freiheits eine massive
freiheitseinschränkung wir müssen so
habe ich es gelesen wir müssen unsere
freiheit im grunde genommen teil nämlich
teilen mit einer zukünftigen generation
und dürfen nicht mehr nur an unsere
eigene freiheit denken wenn wir freiheit
definieren dass wir dass wir schnell mit
dem auto über die autobahn browsen oder
zum shoppen nach new york fliegen dann
heißt das natürlich dass wir der
kommenden generation diese freiheit
berauben
robert habe ich nochmal die gleiche
frage klimaschutz heute damit wir morgen
nicht in einer ökodiktatur landen ist
das aus ihrer sicht eine richtige
aussage oder glauben sie auch das ist
möglich eine entscheidung
das urteil hat tatsächlich die
vorzeichen der debatte aus man nicht
komplett verändert weil wir die
klimadebatte bisher immer so geführt
haben
es gibt die freiheit kann es immer noch
mal gehört des marktes die individuelle
freiheit und die steht gegen regeln
ordnungsrecht abschied vom
verbrennungsmotor und so weiter das hat
das verfassungsgericht ausgehebelt und
hat gesagt klimapolitik ist freiheits
politik sie ist nicht verbotspolitik
oder öko diktatur sie sichert freiheit
insofern ist die die denkt logik die
vorzeichen der debatten haben sich
komplett verändert durch das urteil und
das ist gut dass es endlich passiert ist
und endlich mal gesagt wurde
so und jetzt ist ja auch sehr schnell
gehandelt worden mir ist es ehrlich
gesagt völlig egal ob das wahltaktisch
ist nein nicht fast so schnell ich finde
es super dass eine amtierende regierung
noch die kette ein bisschen ehrgeiziger
sein können aber sie sind jetzt schon
mal ehrgeizig gewesen das muss man sagen
und wenn man sich die zahlen anschaut
hat es zwei konsequenzen erstens die
würfel sind gefallen alle nicht alle
aber die jetzt amtierende regierung und
ihre parteien können sich von diesen
zahlen nicht mehr wegducken und zweitens
wir haben einen höllenjob zu machen
alleine diese zahlen zu erreichen ist
mega anspruchsvoll in allen bereichen
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien ausbau
der stromnetze gebäudesanierung eine
veränderte mobilitätsform
es wird viel geld kosten die deutsche
die deutsche industrie rechnet mit zwei
billionen ungefähr bis zur
klimaneutralität auch staatliches geld
ist fordert eine veränderung des denkens
des denkens von finanzpolitik wir werden
die investitionen in deutschland erhöhen
müssen
wir werden wohl stand anders definieren
müssen all das muss jetzt passieren aber
eben jetzt und das kann ich nur begrüßen
da zählt jeder tag und jede
verpflichtung wie auch die anderen
parteien jetzt noch mitmachen ist
willkommen so hier ist das ein bisschen
zu freundlich was was er aber über die
bundesregierung sagt denn letztlich
hätte die bundesregierung auch das was
das verfassungsgericht jetzt
eingefordert hat schon längst machen
können 2009 10 als dieses
klimaschutzgesetz jahr auf den weg
gekommen ist da war es die cdu und die
csu die eben diese regelung für das jahr
2030 bis 2040 45 ausgenommen hat also
das heißt da haben wir mindestens zwei
jahre zeit verschenkt und damit sind wir
bei herrn altmaier ich frage auch frau
gleich nochmal wie zufrieden sie mit der
politik bisher sind ausgerechnet der
fraktions-vize von der unionsfraktion
herr altmaier andreas jung fordert dass
es einen viel schnelleren anstieg der
co2 zertifikaten angefressen
die preisanstieg geben muss der
zertifikate von 30 auf 45 spricht ja
jetzt auch schon für die gesamte union
also sie wollen offensichtlich leisten
dank dass du von der union glaube ich
mit großer mehrheit geteilt und zwar aus
folgendem grund wir haben uns wie robert
habeck richtig sagt sehr ehrgeizige
ziele gegeben
wir müssen und wollen wir auch einhalten
und nun sind wir nun sind sich auch nun
sind wir davon überzeugt dass es für
alle menschen in deutschland insgesamt
unterm strich preiswerter und
bezahlbarer wird wenn wir die
marktwirtschaft zum einsatz kommen
lassen und nicht dann wenn wir alles
durch regulierung und durch verbote und
durch geben die regeln sondern wenn wir
den menschen die gelegenheit geben durch
findigkeit durch kreativität lösungen zu
ersinnen wie sie co2 einsparen wie sie
diese besteuerung vermeiden indem sie
umweltfreundliche produkte an den markt
bringen und einsetzen so das ist der
ansatz von andreas jung der hat übrigens
viele unterstützung auch gerade bei
jungen
sollten und das sagt bedeutet ja nicht
dass wir keine gesetze im übrigen machen
wir haben doch heute schon gesetze und
richtlinien und verordnungen in den co2
ausstoß von kraftfahrzeugen regeln die
festlegen wie wir die erneuerbaren
ausbauen
traufetter hat ja gesagt ausgerechnet
die cdu csu hat damals verhindert über
das jahr 2030 hinaus zu schauen
wir haben damals darum gerungen ja
richtig und es gab unterschiedliche
auffassung aber ich würde sagen ich war
vor zehn jahren umweltminister da haben
mich die grünen in berlin im bundestag
gesagt wir brauchen keine stromleitung
nach baden württemberg wir müssen dort
windräder bauen seit zehn jahren mussten
führen dieses grünen die landesregierung
einen dritten weg und es sind in diesen
zwei jahren
wir kennen keinen kilometer gebaut
worden dass rossi war bei dem mega star
bei seinem aus den faden ab ich wollte
einmal darauf hinweist dass in allen
landesregierungen die grünen und ich war
selber landes bisher wir kennen uns aus
der zeit den bau von stromtrassen gegen
alle widerstände nach vorne bringen wenn
sich alle so ein hängen würden wie wir
dann wäre das nicht mehr ich habe nicht
nackig wurden sicherheits fraktionen der
grünen ja hat seinerzeit gesagt okay
diese neue froh sein dass nicht
aufgemacht sind handy stadtlohn her
es war ein flottes werk die windräder
bauen und fragen uns nochmal die
pandemie hat uns ja auch etwas gelernt
wenn man nichts tut dann gibt es einen
lock down wenn man nichts tut dann gibt
es eben ein verbot und jeder lockt ohr
hauen das sagt sogar die weko ist eine
kapitulation von politik also wir müssen
etwas tun
wie gelingt es etwas zu tun das nicht
sofort zu sozialen verwerfungen führt
und zeitgleich tatsächlich eben auch
alte industrien entsprechend finanziert
und irgendwie umstrukturiert und neue
möglichkeiten bezahlt und bezahlbar
macht
ich möchte ihnen mal hier eine frohe
kunde bringen ja ich sehe pro jahr 120
150 unternehmen durch die höhle der
löwen und durch meine
investitionstätigkeit viele junge
unternehmen kennen aber auch viele
größere konzerne und ich möchte ihnen
sagen
die botschaft ist angekommen
die nachhaltigkeit gehört in der
wirtschaft zu den top-prioritäten und
das tolle jetzt ist sage ich jetzt sagen
wir sind begeisterung kommen nämlich
gerade aufsichtsrat sowohl ich das
erfahren habe dass sich digitalisierung
mit nachhaltigkeit im viel besser
kombinieren kann
es gibt sogar experten die sagen wir
haben jetzt eine große investitionsboom
in die digitale wirtschaft gehabt der
nächste große investitionsboom wird die
nachhaltigkeits wirtschaft hat und ich
sage ihnen jetzt einfach mal als
beispiel die die unternehmen sind alle
auf diese nachhaltigkeit jetzt schon
richtig geholt und zwar nicht weil es da
einen tollen marketing slogan gibt er
sondern weil es viele gründe dafür gibt
damit man kriegt heute besser
mitarbeiter denn sie sich identifizieren
können
mit einer transparenten
nachhaltigkeitsstrategie in einer firma
da gibt es die kunden legen immer mehr
wert auf nachhaltige produkte gibt es
geschäftspartner sie schauen dich hab
mal anders sagen wenn du eine
nachhaltige transparenz aufweisen kannst
und dann gibt es auch noch den
kapitalmarkt da habe ich ja hier die
bösen kapitalisten wie da gibt es fonds
aktionäre anforderungen an der börse die
jetzt alle viel genauer auf
nachhaltigkeit schauen und es gibt
sogenannte impact investoren nur in
einer hd unternehmen investieren und ich
sage ihnen jetzt ein kleines die jungen
unternehmen wir erleben derzeit eine
wirklich erfreuliche gründer neugründer
generation in deutschland die sind an
die wollen alle nachhaltigkeit
wir haben nachhaltigkeit in ihrem
unternehmensprinzip die lebende auch und
jetzt kommen zur punkt sie setzten diese
nachhaltigkeit mit digitalen
instrumenten um
zum beispiel dass nachhaltigkeit das co2
management in einem konzern auf einer
software basierten lösung nicht mehr mit
faxgeräten und und und mit mit mit
zettelwirtschaft wie in der in der
öffentlichen verwaltung sondern aus
modernster basis und das beschleunigt
die transparenz hier des masses dann
nachhaltigkeit erreichen wir wie
erreichen wir diese ziele ist die frage
herr kofler ja nur war diese riesen
ziele
ja wir haben den zeitraum jetzt nochmals
verkürzt wo wir uns dekarbonisierung
wollen wo wir zeitgleich aus öl
aussteigen aus atom aussteigen aus gas
aussteigen wie erreichen wir diese
umwelt sind ja mit der effizientesten
aller wirtschafts ordnungen nämlich mit
der marktwirtschaft und definitiv nicht
mit der staatswirtschaft denn das
langsamste und das dreckwasser sind der
wirtschaft gibt ist die öffentliche
verwaltung und das haben wir in der
pandemie ja schon wieder mal gesehen
entschuldigung ja hier die öffentliche
verwaltung hätte ja schon seit zehn
jahren digitalisiert werden können der
staat hätte als bannerträger einer
digitalisierung ein leuchtturmprojekt
digitalisierung der verwaltung auf sind
aber sind es vielleicht auch die
versäumnisse der vergangenheit ohne dass
wir über die vergangenheit reden wollen
auch der industrie sondern es in die
marktwirtschaft für ihre ziele arbeiten
die marktwirtschaft will das leben sie
eine zweite zusammen hatten sie nur 2
einen preis geben weil sie gedacht
nachgefragt haben co2 preisen haben
das unternehmen sehe schon dass dann für
die mitarbeiter die mit dem flugzeug zu
dienstreisen und besprechungen pflegen
einen höheren preis zahlen muss wird
vielleicht sagen wir machen eine
video-konferenz damit spart man co2 ein
und wir haben und das ist ganz wichtig
immer gesagt für die einkommensschwachen
werden wir einen sozialen ausgleich
schaffen
wir haben in diesem jahr zehn milliarden
euro eingesetzt um die strompreise
stabilisieren die wären andernfalls
deutlich gestiegen mit 100 euro mehr pro
dreiköpfige familie und das haben wir
mit den einnahmen finanziert aus der co2
verpressung die seit dem ersten januar
inkasso ist wir sind immer noch bei das
ist ist zustand der altmaier wir sind
bei der frage wie erreichen wir diese
ziele die so groß sind dass einem auch
der atem stocken kann wenn man sich ein
bisschen ausführlicher damit beschafft
frage befasst was würden sie sagen
sollte jetzt klugerweise als nächstes
geschehen hat die politik richtige ziele
formuliert fehlt nur noch die
beantwortung der frage wie wir die
erreichen wurden wichtig ist ja dass wir
mal aufhören vermeintliche sachen
gegeneinander auszuspielen die im grunde
genommen nur synergetisch zusammenwirken
können eine soziale marktwirtschaft hat
immer einen rahmen einen ordnungsrahmen
und momentan ist dieser ordnungsrahmen
eben nicht auf sehr viel beschleunigung
von dieser entwicklung von technologien
aber fragen auch deren verbreitung in
einer gesellschaft da kann der co2 preis
ganz ganz viel dran tun aber eben nicht
alles transparenz wäre zum beispiel dass
ich mir wünschen würde von einer neuen
bundesregierung einmal richtig
transparent hinzulegen wie ich welche
lenkungswirkung sind mit
unterschiedlichen preiswerte reise
steuermaßnahmen subventionen etc
verbunden schaffen die das gerade uns
richtung nachhaltigkeit zu schieben oder
ziemlich dagegen da sind die typisch
immer genannten 50 milliarden von klima
schädlichen subventionen sich einmal 1
was man immer lukrieren könnte also neu
verwenden um eine beschleunigung
hinzubekommen
das nächste ist natürlich das klingt
super aber die prozente von unternehmen
die das wirklich schon konsequent machen
oder machen können unter den aktuellen
regelungen sind ja klein und das sind
also der rat für nachhaltige entwicklung
hat gerade erst am montag umfrage heraus
gegeben wo drei millionen unternehmen in
deutschland noch nicht besonders schnell
auf dem weg sind und wir bei 0,15
prozent derjenigen sind die wirklich
nachhaltig sind warum und was ist ein
wirklicher treiber wichtige treiber sind
regulierungs anordnung war die e größer
das unternehmen desto wichtiger aber
auch aufklärung förderprogramm
unnatürlich der zug den sie sagen von
konsumenten mitarbeiter erinnerung vom
den finanzmarkt taxonomie lässt sich
nach vorgaben für nachhaltiges
investment sicherlich noch
ambitionierter formulieren als bisher
und wir sind mit dem anteil
nachhaltige finanzen sehr klein im
vergleich zu einem riesigen teil davon
überhaupt nicht wirklich großen ändert
sich darin deutlich wurde wie verändert
es sich möglichst schnell sein wie sehr
schlaue regulative oder standard setzen
die vorgaben machen so dass sich die
pioniere sehr viel schneller noch wieder
absetzen gesagt also wie ein race zum
topf haben anstatt dass sie in einer
tour versuchen zu blockieren und dann
alles regulativ es ist schlimm und
deshalb dürfen wir das überhaupt nicht
in einen virtuosen zyklus von innovation
und anpassung der standard receiver
spannend finde gebote verbote verbote
ich habe zufällig oder ihnen gegeben
dass sie super finden das eine mehr weg
pflicht eingeführt wird und zufällig in
die unternehmen auch investiert sind die
davon profitieren was ich denn jetzt der
unterschied zwischen einer mehr
wehrpflicht und eine einweg verbot da
müssen sie gleich auf gehen auf ihre
twitter kann wo haben sie auf meinem weg
genau deshalb finde ich das nicht
ehrlich diese debatte es geht darum
unter welchen bedingungen können welche
geschäftsmodelle möglichst schnell sich
verbreiten so dass ich jetzt einen abos
label draufkleben oder ein standard
label leinenpflicht oder wie auch immer
aber man kann es künstlich gegeneinander
ausspielen anstatt endlich zu sagen
mitte in zusammenarbeit mit denen immer
unternehmer innen die nach vorne gehen
wollen damit so tolle initiative 2° wie
act neues wirtschaftswunder
wir haben ganz klare vorschläge unter
welchen veränderungen der politischen
rahmenbedingungen sie viel schneller
können leichte und setzt vielleicht kann
man das ganze problem einmal am beispiel
des autos erklären ist des deutschen
liebstes kind da kann man auf der einen
seite einen co2 preis auf benzin und auf
diesel erheben das machen wir auch
mittlerweile schon seit 2000 21 das
heißt der sprit kostet 67 18 mehr
das soll eine lenkungswirkung entfalten
das soll praktisch den umstieg auf die
elektromobilität beim kunden forcieren
dann kann man auf der anderen seite auch
flotten grenzwerte senken so dass die
autoindustrie sich darauf einstellt dass
sie elektroautos produziert also das
heißt man kann mit verschiedenen
instrumenten versuchen so eine
transformation wie der umstieg in die
elektromobilität möglichst schnell
hinzubekommen so das einzige problem
eben dass wir das einzige problem ja der
einzige problem das wir haben ist dass
das natürlich belastung für die bürger
darstellt und da ist das große problem
bei den energiekosten dass leute die
relativ wenig verdienen dass die von
ihrem haushaltseinkommen relativ viel
dafür zahlen für energie also fürs
heizen und auch für das autofahren und
das ist die große soziale
herausforderung die es jetzt zu lösen
gilt
das und damit sind wir eben bei etwas
was wir uns auf der einen seite alle
wünschen nämlich klimaschutz und auf der
anderen seite bei der großen frage wie
man das bezahlt auch wenn ich verstehe
und aus der diskussion hier verstehe
dass es nicht nur eine diskussion um den
preis geben soll so ist das für das gros
der menschen in diesem land doch eine
reale frage was kostet das
stürme überschwemmungen
naturkatastrophen werden mehr und kommen
eher um den klimawandel zu bremsen muss
der co2 ausstoß von kohlendioxid in die
luft bläst muss zahlen
die bundesregierung startet dieses jahr
mit 25 euro pro tonne co2
in fünf jahren soll der preis bei 55
euro liegen
kosten die wir alle spüren allein fürs
heizen immobilienverbände rechnen vor
für ein einfamilienhaus mit 160
quadratmetern und einer ölheizung müssen
239 euro dieses jahr mehr bezahlt werden
527 euro sind es in fünf jahren sieht
man eine mögliche entlastung beim
strompreis ab bleiben immer noch 325
euro zusätzlich für den hausbesitzer und
das bei einem vergleichsweise niedrigen
co2 preis von 55 euro würden heute schon
umweltschäden eingerechnet müsste die
tonne co2 sogar 195 euro kosten so das
umweltbundesamt und damit sind wir
wieder bei der politik herr altmaier
herr laschet sagt der befreiung staat
solle straffer gezogen werden mit
größeren schritten und früherer
preisbildung am markt heißt das nicht
auf gut deutsch der bepreisung skat
heilige mutter gottes könnte er nicht
einfach sagen dass es teurer wird ja
aber das ist doch damit auch sehr
deutlich zum ausdruck gebracht dass wir
einen preis festsetzen für die
freisetzung von klimaschädlichen co2
emissionen und was das für den bürger
kostet ist eine andere frage
weil wir nämlich das geld was wir dann
etwa von den mineralölgesellschaften an
der tankstelle einnehmen auch an die
zurückgeben die es brauchen zum beispiel
im ländlichen raum
wenn ich hier in berlin wohne und ich
bin ja seit 20 jahren auch als
abgeordneter hier die meiste zeit dann
kann ich auch mit dem fahrrad zu viel
und bestimmungen gehen ich komme mit dem
bus fahren ich kann leichter mit dem
essen erfahren so und deshalb haben wir
uns entschieden haben wir uns
entschieden in ländlichen räumen
beispielsweise die entfernungspauschale
das geht nicht nur für pkws gilt auch
für andere möglichkeiten zu erhöhen
wenn wir jetzt schon haben wir jetzt
schon die entfernungspauschale gibt es
schon was tun wir in der zukunft um
diese großen hohen ziele zu erreichen
was wird der liter benzin kosten in fünf
jahren
naja also jürgen trittin hat mal gesagt
vor einiger zeit ist schon lange her
fünf d-mark und das ist nicht
eingetreten
wir haben heute mit der co2 bepreisung
eine situation dass der sprit immer noch
günstiger ist eine tankstelle als vor
einigen jahren als die mineralölpreise
sehr viel höher waren auf den
rohölmärkten was wir jetzt brauchen ist
ein klarer berechenbarer vaart und wenn
die wirtschaft sich darauf einstellen
kann
die autoproduzenten und viele andere
dann werden auch diese preiserhöhung bei
den bürgern nicht alle ankommen sondern
dann wird man rechtzeitig neue modelle
alternativer antriebe elektro autos
haben wir geben dieses jahr einige
milliarden euro aus für die umweltprämie
um elektroautos anzuschaffen wir geben
einige milliarden euro aus zwischen fünf
und zehn milliarden wahrscheinlich
dieses jahr im gebäude zu dämmen fenster
dämmmaterialien neue heizung einzubauen
dadurch kann der bürger eben diese
mehrkosten vermeiden
dabei helfen wir uns fragen vorher aber
herrn habeck was sie glauben dass in
fünf jahren der liter benzin kosten wird
und was der liter heizöl
es sind das nicht dinge mit denen die
leute jetzt irgendwie mal konfrontiert
werden sollten damit sie rechnen können
damit sie nicht nur hören gibt es nicht
zum nulltarif
das hängt jetzt von der politischen
debatte ab wie schnell der co2 preis an
steigt noch einmal das hatten wir von
einer halben stunde das argument wenn
man alles über den preis regelt dann
muss er sehr schnell auf 180 200 euro
ansteigen dass ich das fdp-modell ich
warne davor das zu tun wenn der moderat
an schoder schneller an steigt auf die
55 euro auf 60 euro im nächsten jahr
dann wäre das eine verdoppelung
gegenüber
je nachdem wie man rechnet 25 verdoppelt
ist 50 60 noch ein bisschen drauf
gegenüber dem was wir erlebt haben als
es ist ein sprung also es ist und das
ist eine akademische betrag ich will
noch einmal nur sechs liter benzin dann
kostet gegenüber dem den 718 ps drauf
gekommen sind nochmal das doppelte wenn
man es dem preis verdoppelt